it was supposed to be a private act
but for lee nickel it's been the most
public of ordeals a video she filmed of
herself having sex
then stolen after an icloud hack and
without her permission
leaked online i couldn't look at myself
in the mirror for a long long time and
still even at this point
i'll look at myself and i feel dirty i
feel sick
because that's no longer private to me
that's that no longer in my head just
belongs to me because
a large part of the population has seen
something that they shouldn't have seen
now she's taking legal action against
mind geek
owner of pornhub the world's most
popular porn site
when i seen that i was trending in the
top three on that that particular site i
think that's when the anger
completely set in because my question
was why
and how is this allowed like this this
isn't legal like
i haven't put this out there i met lee
in south london where she's a footballer
for crystal palace
but now her battle is being waged here
in america
lee is one of 34 women taking civil
action against
mind geek in a case filed here in the
u.s
today some were raped as children others
were trafficked all claim
explicit content of them was posted on
online porn sites
without their permission and without any
verification checks
their representative is former trump
lawyer michael bowe
is this a moment of reckoning for the
online porn industry
you get away with it until you don't and
there's lots of factors in that right
but you're worried the reckoning right
at some point
the world's eyes turn on you and you
don't have an answer
it's the online porn industry's me too
moment do you think
i think it's much more than the me too
movement i think it's more serious than
me too
i mean you have you have a handful of
men
who are making a lot of money
exploiting god knows how many hundreds
of thousands of women
i arrange a video call with one of them
stephanie not her real name is from the
midwest but claims she was trafficked
around the us and coerced into sex
the videos were then posted on mind geek
websites
if i didn't make enough money he would
rape me and beat me and put me down
i didn't ask to put those videos up
there there were times i was suicidal
in a statement pornhub said we're
currently reviewing and investigating
the complaint filed today
pornhub has zero tolerance for illegal
content and investigates any complaint
or allegation made about content on our
platforms
but if successful the women making the
claim could be awarded hundreds of
millions of dollars in damages
it's illuminating aspects of an industry
which some say has been operating in the
dark
for far too long martha kellner sky news
new york